thanks Nate to cut the glass let's go
hey guys want talk they're good tire
obviously on this tire so in this video
I am gonna show you how to remove the
who you'll find a pump jar find it all
and hopefully patch it and get it
working as good as new guy he's not I
got the wheel off of the tractor the
first thing you need to do is obviously
Jack the tractor up somehow
this is why I do I usually just tilted
on its axis fairly and it's just a
minefield tractor push up the side rest
against something in the back there and
you know a couple of steadies underneath
and that we even get this wheel off okay
so on most lawn tractors you just saw a
plastic cup over the hop here so simply
a first cause option is cooler off she
just prized off okay so in this case all
we have here is the here's the axle is
retaining clip and that water so all we
need to do is just forced us quite out
so we're using something like a a small
screwdriver like this
just leave a lot and push it over and do
a boozer like i just off there
once you do that take the wash it off
and that we all can then be way Koval
hopefully yeah you may find that yours
use me of our attaining not you know
it's just a normal mop on there or it
may have a split pen
realize you were just off to you know
remove this poppin similar situation and
and just get the wheel off okay so it
should just be a simple case of sorry
jiggling the wheel off so just okay it's
obviously the first thing you need to do
is a complete tie up so you can either
use our compressor or in this case I'm
just use my my basic or pump yeah that's
perfectly adequate for a track that they
are so come pop okay so obviously get
adopt a substantial pressure to where
the air walking over the wall there's
opposite hällnäs tear somewhere so we'll
get up to pressure and although it's the
move the next stage okay so what we want
to do now is we need to get some sort of
solution soapy solution so all I've got
years on old just a little spraying off
our flasher many like household it sort
of displease that you get or you can buy
one you know bonito ever um a little
water in it and quite a lot of air
philia liquid or you know any sort of
detail gent and what what I do is just
spray it all over the tire and just to
see where we can see the leaking so it's
basically a homemade leak detector will
spit all over the tire and then
hopefully you'll see the air bubbles
come out and then out that way we'll be
able to find a leak so just you know
don't hang about just spray a lot a lot
of this on keeps fill in the tail
so you should soon see the week you know
yes
he says yeah see you there commas
picking up see the bubbles there
[Music]
so that's what you're looking for you're
looking for our you know obvious escape
of here and then the tire see you there
okay so again just clear it quickly see
the big bubble here but we'll check
again see familiar souvenir that's the
idea
so keep my eye on it what I'm gonna do
is dry this off in the market with a
marker that was marked at the seahorse
of just mark a couple of white marks
yeah see the hole there that took my
finger yes it was a tool kit here the
repair kit yeah they're all type 2 here
which he just pierced through the hole
and just got a robbed and that cleans
the area we've got two here whoever
thread through the actual plugs these
are the clothes that affect fillets are
rubber strips yeah I was I'm sorry glee
alright good in the inside I thought it
was a rubber off string or something
effectively they thread to do this to
you force it through the tire and then
pull us over and it leaves it the plug
and then you turn off and that's that's
effect where I'll show you how we did I
know okay so what you want to do firstly
I want to get this draw tool obviously
will establish where the hallways so
what do is just stab the stroll through
the hole and just you know pool and I
notice they sort of fail the area
unclean the area so now maybe saw me out
comes open we do that spot so just
get it and twist that who out quickly
[Music]
and again pull it out and just repeat
this process you know five or six times
they've got a nice clear haul hoping you
got close up here's a handle here's a
tool go in there and see that stick out
slowly
[Music]
so effectively failing the all okay so I
do know is the move when he steps on
this packaging I saw just pull this out
no we need to do is just thread this
through this eyelet here you see this
ila
just thread this through
it's pretty tough courses quick sake
usually robbery so it's really Stefano
let's get it roughly halfway okay so how
this works is top edge of the eye it's
obviously sealed so that allows you to
force down into the tire but the top
edge of the eyelet if you can see it's
not joined so once you give that plug
into the tire and pull forcefully back
you know and the tool we are this
obviously is opening and wheeshes a tool
but leaves the plug in the tire and all
them and see that and they're not so
faithfully it trim the plug pump it up
check for leaks
and that should be us demonstrate that
no here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna this is just the droll oh just
mark them with a Wohlers so we're gonna
take this out and we're gonna twist this
end a short distance and then yank it
out quickly I wasn't sure you know take
this out
[Music]
finger wall with us push your hand will
go if you can see that it's probably I
don't know halfway in and then we need
to do is just yank there so forcefully
and quickly like that well that leaves
your with is using the plug stock and
the wall I'm associate marked that mark
that's what we need to do you know it
was just trim knees all the little off
the tread wear with our craft knife and
we'll probably take it up again spray it
with solution and just make sure the
week's gone okay so just got one of
these craft knifes what do you know is
just trim these off hopefully when
you're doing this these nurseries are
sharp so don't there / they tell you
again and we'll be back to square one
but all I'm doing here is this I've got
I just bore the tread hold on the one
end of the clog and just gently
so just gently cough just pumped up
yeah we'll just split some solution I
know yeah and see it's totally sealed
[Music]
look it's a puncture fixed I'll get this
up to pleasure and we'll get the wheel
back on one more okay look wheels off
just use all that grease er doesn't
bother you don't have any of it
I'm just doing it because it feels off
and then simply set the wheel back on
okay sobs they want to get the wheel
back on washer on start clip in the
groove these up here I walk on pliers to
squeeze this orange
[Music]
that's a really quick top cut back on
the Scott
yeah nut sauce that's it done okay guys
that's it fixed perfect if they liked
the video in any way please give it a
thumbs up I'll leave links in the
description to all the the tools used
especially that appear cut and the new
here likes these types of videos please
subscribe my channel go ahead and
subscribe there any comments please
leave in the comments guys I always
answer comments
[Music]